[Musik]
[Applaus]
nur in der er geboren war in welchen die
uhrzeit komplett verpennt mich hier ich
hab gerade zehn stunden schlafen
der plan für heute ist dass wir das
geplant einmal ja das ist heute morgen
werden ist einfach rufen gilt das werde
ich machen
video fertig sein und dann werden gehen
das meinst du gerade deswegen soll ich
den hotspot geben in pokémon wer spielt
das noch
deswegen bin ich für diese dinge und
damit halt wirklich irgendwann mit mehr
kälte wenn die ganze der nase haben
viele hatten mich gefragt wieso ich
eigentlich nicht beantwortet die er
nicht eingeladen weil den ort oder sage
ich nicht welche für bezahlt werde die
haben nicht auf meinem kanal hier
irgendwie gebremst oder keine ahnung was
gemacht ich bin fußballfan und ich liebe
tief sitzt ich bin halt zu spielen sagte
werder bremen fan
gerade 16 minuten vergangen bei
radieschen und ja ich habe hier
irgendwie das halbe bad unter wasser
gesetzt junge diese kamera die laute
jetzt in einem laden und werden es tut
mir wirklich leid mit direkter
reichweite sollen ich bin ich gut filme
passiert bin ich gut über gesang
verleiht dankeschön bäume wie teuer
werden frühstück bekommen
ein vorzeichen enten zeigen aber der
zoomfaktor wieder mega bin ich unten die
mit songs wie die frauen jetzt durch
dahinten hollywood los geht's doch mein
fokus geht wieder deutlich an welcher
stelle näher gekommen
genauso aus mega gut überlegt und wasser
[Applaus]
lugano kam darüber einig werden
ich schaute vorbei wir stehen jetzt hier
draußen stand und jetzt will einer der
ersten deutschen der deutschen glaubt
erwartet schwierige sie verachtet werden
unser fokus weil die kleinen laufen
jetzt zurück zum hof feldmann
ich habe vertrag von ihr und aktiv voran
jetzt aber diese agenten kriterium
hauptübel mit vornamen
wir wollten eigentlich
[Musik]
wir möchten ja auch arbeiten
der heißt ein body styling
ich verstehe diesen fokus weg wir haben
gerade bei youtube geschrieben und seine
tipps und danach mit euro
wir wurden auf jeden fall von ina von
youtube gaming bei dem alter werden
versteckte raum wurde zudem hatte
eingeladen weil die ihm die barbecue und
pool party machen also fahren wir da
hätten
was aber ganz gut nach vorn spielen ecke
die wohnung wird mit ihren da vorne
gefallen drin waren
wir waren grad entwickler vier von hier
aber hat der spieler nur bestellt werden
jetzt zurück zum hotel fahren wieder
gerade einfach irgendwie 12 uhr wir sind
wieder im hotel angekommen und der
verkehr nimmt einfach sozusagen 8 und
jetzt einfach komplett still stand
überall stehen wir sind jetzt wieder
wachsen warum ist die klimaanlage auf
jeden fall wieder modell überhaupt sich
der fernsehshow wieder an wir sind jetzt
wieder hotel waren gekommen und werden
jetzt schlafen gehen weil wir morgen
wieder früh raus müssen morgen werde ich
keinen noch hochladen weil ich für
morgen schon anderes video eingeplant
hatte deswegen ja
[Musik]